[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
friday july 1st i'm julie chang for the
wall street journal filling in for zoe
thomas
elon musk and twitter have been in talks
about a 44 billion dollar acquisition
since april so three months in what's
the holdup the tesla and spacex ceo has
said there's three issues standing in
the way lining up financing for the deal
winning shareholder approval and bots he
thinks twitter is rife with fake
accounts so much so that he put the deal
on hold while demanding the company turn
over data on its fake or spam accounts
now some have speculated that the move
was an attempt at renegotiating or
scuttling the deal altogether whatever
the case in recent weeks musk got that
data
but how useful was it to him really and
where does the deal go next here to help
answer those questions is wsj tech
reporter sarah needleman who's been
following the story hi sarah thanks for
coming on the show hi thanks for having
me
so elon musk got what he asked for from
twitter he got this huge data dump
exactly how much data are we talking
here so he received historical tweak
data and access to the company's
so-called fire hose of tweets uh the
fire hose shows the full flood of tweets
and keep in mind that people post about
hundreds of millions of times a day on
the platform according to the company
and he's accessing this data in near
real time so it's a large volume of
information and what was included in
that data
it's really just tweets and the
timestamps and dates of when those
tweets were put out so there aren't any
direct messages for example dms it
doesn't include any personal or private
information from users like their ip
addresses or email addresses
so it's really just tweets and their
timestamps
since it's just tweets and time stamps
can that information actually be used to
identify bots and if so i mean how
accurate would that be well you could
use it to find
some bots what some of the experts i
spoke to say they described it as low
hanging fruit so these would be obvious
instances of bots just by you know
looking through the data certainly if a
particular account is tweeting more
times in a short period than a human
possibly could that's a good indication
of a bot but it also could dig up bots
that are arguably useful um ones that
just post say weather alerts or photos
of cue animals it would miss
sophisticated human-like bot behavior
because you really need some of that
personal data to cross-check to make
sure a user is human or not and these
bots are very sophisticated and so to go
through at least in a short period of
time because we know that shareholders
twitter shareholders are voting on the
deal
later this summer so he is strapped for
time to go through it and parse that
data to figure out which accounts maybe
bots and not just bots in general but
ones that are spewing spam as opposed to
like i said helpful information like
weather alerts
so that actually raises another question
how do you determine what's considered a
fake or spam account or not right
there's no standard industry definition
so
if mr musk and twitter were to compare
say just analysis of the fire hose data
and nothing else and keep it more of an
apples to apples comparison they would
have to agree on what constitutes a bad
bot or malicious behavior and come
across some sort of a universal
definition
and this goes back to the point they're
saying that when twitter comes up with
this estimate it does have access to
that personal data we talked about
earlier and that's something mr musk
doesn't have and critter also uses
humans you know employees to analyze
the fire hose data and that's something
mr musk wouldn't be able to replicate so
the comparison to twitter's
process for estimating
spam on its platform isn't something
that mr musk or really anyone could
easily replicate so elon musk got this
data what does that mean for the deal
because he's been saying that he thinks
the bots make up about 20 of accounts
twitter has said they only make up five
percent of accounts so would this
discrepancy be enough grounds for him to
pull out of the deal
he could try but again we he has to come
up with a
number and share the process for coming
up with it and making convincing
argument that whatever he finds is a
perhaps a more accurate number or that
twitter was either dishonest or just did
a poor job of assessing
its platform and again that's very
difficult to do when you can't compare
to their process that's done internally
another factor considers that twitter's
number is based on its population of
monetizable daily users
and we also know that many people log on
to twitter just to reposts they don't
actually tweet themselves
you know that's a significant share of
the platform's users and that points to
another limitation of the fire hose data
because that could meaningly affect how
percentages of users are calculated
you know so the experts i spoke to say
it would be surprising that if he comes
up with a different number it may not be
enough to change the course of the deal
or the terms of the deal and what
happens next in the deal you mentioned
that there's going to be a vote later in
the summer is there anything else that
we can look forward to
uh that is a major next step but we're
talking about someone who has surprised
us many instances over these last few
months
so we have to see if mr musk will come
forward and say that his team has come
up with a different number and perhaps
he will argue that
twitter's process was faulty
but again it's difficult to know exactly
whether or not that would be enough to
change the course of the deal given the
factors we talked about earlier
so it remains to be seen but the next
step that we know about
being on the books or being on the
record is this upcoming shareholder vote
so between now and then it's anyone's
guess as to what mr musk might say
at an event or on twitter itself
speaking of which mr musk hasn't tweeted
since june 21st so as of
thursday that would be nine days and
pretty unusual for mr musk who is known
to be a serial tweeter and the fact that
he's been quiet is very interesting or
it's at least somewhat surprising so all
eyes are on
that platform to see what he says next
and when he says it next we're talking
about a person who's known for making
news based on a single tweet and now
we're saying there's news in the fact
that he hasn't tweeted um is in itself
also pretty interesting i agree that is
pretty interesting all right that was
our tech reporter sarah needleman sarah
thanks so much for being here thanks for
having me
and that's it for tech news briefing
this week we had production assistants
from ariana aspuru we had editorial
support from scott salloway are
supervising producer is chris zinsley
our executive producer is kateri yokum
and i'm your host julie chang filling in
for zoe thomas a quick programming note
will be off on monday for independence
day but we'll be back in your feed on
tuesday thanks for listening and have a
great weekend
[Music]
[Music]
you